[Musique]
aujourd'hui on vous aide à trouver le
meilleur biscuits à offrir au père noël
un test de goût de biscuits au gingembre
dubai champlain à brossard nous avons la
version dans american la version
suédoise est la version sans gluten on
arrête de magasiner et on vient goûte
déjà fait depuis ce contingent c'est
parfait c'est ça qu'on a besoin d'eux on
dégoûte a aujourd'hui à goutte leur
réconfort
moi je trouve que le parfum des épices
ensemble vraiment quelque chose de super
chaleureux
aimez vous soulevez jean-louis j'adore
le jai pas s'il n'est pas une gemme je
peux tu t'es fait tout et
l'angine des biscuits au gingembre c'est
un dérivé britannique des biscuits aux
épices de pays environnants à la
scandinavie l'europe du nord la recette
traditionnelle britannique s'est
vraiment farine beurre gingembre mais là
c'est clair comme le golden syrup
évidemment les anglais vont avoir
tendance à prendre le bisc aux jambes
avec du thé do i sava puis un petit et
un petit goût à la fin que différents
n'étaient pas les bons vins j'en suis là
c'est un biscuit sans gluten ok on
vienne de comprendre gérait des fag lui
tel un robot
j'aime beaucoup plus parce que les plus
croustillants les primeurs on goûte
beaucoup le gingembre dans ce produit en
particulier mais quand on regarde là les
ingrédients y apparaît pas
nécessairement très très tôt dans la
liste d'ingrédients la majorité des
produits sans gluten rond une liste
d'ingrédients un peu plus longue parce
que faudra aussi ajouter des fois
d'autres agents pour venir essayer de de
reproduire la texture que où la
structure que nous amène le gluten dans
un pain dans un biscuit
invaincus chez eux
jamais loin
il ya c'est quoi cette grimace pour les
jambes ça la puissante et séduit la sasp
et tu pourquoi je sais pas il n'y a pas
de goût allons on sent presque pas le
gingembre comme pas du tout c'est de
vrais gingembre c'est dommage il
faudrait en mettre plus
c'est vrai j'ai les jambes ça goûte et
l'eau y goûte pas dans les ingrédients
de ce produit là c'est la mélasse qui
arrivent comme troisième ingrédient on
la goûte beaucoup quand on regarde les
recettes sur internet dans les livres de
recettes ce sont presque toujours de la
mélasse dans les biscuits au gingembre
ou niveau des aigreurs en fait c'est de
l'huile de palme et modifier puis
l'huile de canola l'huile de palme
modifié c'est une ville qui est quand
même assez riche en graisses saturées
tic pas nécessairement une huile de très
grande qualité cd bis rue du commerce
est pas étonnant non plus devoir de
l'huile de palme dans ces biscuits l'op
[Musique]
début ce cas ces billets avec 7 buts
plus
stéphie s'agrippe c'est ce qui m'a bien
pas du tout girard
c'est bon non ça ne change pas je vais
faire quoi vous allez c'est pas parce
qu'il est mince - dessus en général au
niveau du secret du lion à peu près tout
la même quantité de sucre c'est normal
pour des biscuits les eaux rien
d'alarmant à ce niveau là après cela
dépend de la quantité quand on consomme
on se souhaite définitivement celui qui
est le plus intéressant au goût ginger
snaps suit traditionnellement ensuite de
moi c'est vraiment ce biscuit là que
j'ai trouvé qui ressemblait le plus à
une recette maison très courte liste
d'ingrédients le sucre apparaît en
deuxième pas beaucoup de sucre et j'ai
pas le droit mais c'est la petite
tricherie aujourd'hui dans l'histoire
des femmes qui votre faute dont 50
goûteurs ont retrouvé leur coeur
d'enfant 12 ont bien aimé d'aircel ont
été surpris par les modèles 22 ont
choisi des biscuits suédois n'y a qu'à
mais qu'en pense le père noël
bonjour père noël
c'est vous qui allez avoir le fin mot de
l'histoire ancienne a rien dans ce que
vos amis lumière alors c'est confirmé le
père noël et sans gluten joaillier neil
[Musique]